c'est parti on va commencer la session
doublage comme tous les jours moi j'ai
ma petite routine je viens hop hop petit
café on regarde les images et c'est
parti Pauline je suis prêt
on y va
j'ai la pression d'huile en zone rouge
j'adore je commençais à mouiller mec je
te dis pas comment je retenais les
chevaux mirage reste planqué mirage fais
gaffe te fais pas remarquer et oh
doucement doucement pourquoi tu
m'agresses je pensais qu'après ce rodé
on était potos
moi je suis mirage on est
transats impressionne qui est des gens
qui me regardent donc j'essaie de livrer
le meilleur mede de moi-même mais si je
pleure c'est plus dedans désolé
faut que tu apprennes à détendre mon
grand bah je te jure
ça c'est une appro par exemple c'était
pas je pense qu'ils vont la garder